click on the timestamp in the
description to skip this intro then read
the comment section of people asking for
the timestamp to skip this intro
firstly huge announcement bob lazar has
donated element 115 and i heard that
jeremy corbell is working to stretch
this 10 minutes of content into a three
and a half hour documentary
personally i'm looking forward to it
being narrated by mickey rourke because
i don't think i have enough thoughts of
what is going on already floating around
in my head
secondly there will be new thumbnails
out with the old clean images and in
with the cutouts of kurt in a
provocative pose with a guest and the
contrived white borders with the red
arrow since that's not overplayed on
youtube why not achieve the equivalence
of mind uploading and give my soul to
the algorithm in that vein i'm going to
make sure that i say like this video and
smash that subscribe button call to
actions ending videos with so what do
you guys think leave a comment below
about something vapid that wastes
everyone's time for the sake of
demonstrating engagement to the platform
more reactions to memes with guests i
think that the popularity of these
standalone meme clips more than
justifies the degradation of the
character and self-respect they bring to
a channel we'll also have different
types of reaction videos so for example
sabine hostenfelder reacts to eric
weinstein trying to explain a point
without jargon and irritation that
people aren't understanding that the gin
is a sense making smooth structure on a
fiber bundle over the space of the twin
nuclei problems of the shiab operator's
pullback of the n squared revolutions
linda molten howe reacts to kurt's
leather jacket leo gura reacts to
antipsychotic medication
also for every one podcast i'll snip
about six clips of it and post it to the
main channel to increase view counts at
the expense of cluttering your feed
because you don't necessarily need to
associate quality with every single post
on this channel that's ridiculous you
can skip it if you don't like i mean you
can skip everything except the patreon
and the sponsor requests which will
remain approximately forty percent of
the video another announcement is that
there will be more pushback from kurt
especially toward the guests who
repeatedly admit that their
interpretation of quantum mechanics is
not testable and that the data that they
have is anecdotal about something
perhaps there's an nda involved with me
repeatedly saying okay well where's the
evidence and then smugly lean back as
they admit in self-defeat ah kurt wow
you got me what a brilliant question
that i've never considered before
i will then follow suit with a liberal
use of the word grifter and writhe in my
own self-importance anonymously on
social media another announcement for
the ask me anythings the more sober and
ordinary the username the better alien
alcoholic asks have you heard of
facilities that are housing live aliens
this question comes from poop digg
what does he think i know this question
comes from dom to long
question to ross from
euphoricgr4674 as a journalist who
understands we didn't get all these
names and of course priority will be
given to alien smegma collector
which by the way i just found out is
mick west's pseudonym on animal crossing
on this theme if you want to hear what
the other theolocution guest has to say
then you're going to have to pay for a
premium subscription people are always
like super determinism isn't the thing
they never bother to look at the
literature
to see what models people have actually
worked with
recently i've come to several
conclusions like that the
fringe is indeed misinformed and the
innovation will come from the
conservative center on this account i
think string theory is probably correct
many worlds is probably correct that
area 51 picture of an alien is indeed
genuine i think real aliens show
evidence of
polygon edges and
clearly pixelated texture maps i've also
realized that i need to stop smiling so
much it's a bit off-putting to the
guests to be so welcoming and amiable
that the witness is described
that uh
you know we we hope eventually sisterly
and dynasty if you like to from the
heartbeat of the consciousness than
anything else though i knew it was the
superset
and about two years i'm also going to be
ramping up the amount that i say this
podcast is technical four times in the
same three minute video because i don't
think my introductions are stilted and
verbose and pompous enough the first
hour can be rather technical in these
podcasts we tend to delve into
intricacies into equations sometimes
into meticulous technicalities you've
surveyed this channel before as we've
done an unduly technical dive into
donald hoffman's research papers also to
reflect the ufo content toe will be
rebranded as ufto and logos will be
changed to a picture of myself
phlegmatically staring at the camera it
is after all all about me and not the
subject
lastly there will be more of me
pensively looking off onto my desk at
some unseen object as if i'm silently
having a profound insight but i'm truly
thinking about if my poor wife has used
up the plastic cups we set aside for her
to urinate in because this is the only
bathroom in our condo and i'm four hours
into this podcast live
you know what
i don't think i've imitated jordan
peterson's mannerisms enough this year
so i'll be working on that as well
thank you and i hope you enjoy the
upcoming changes now hold on while i
observe the chat explaining to people
that premiering isn't the same as live
streaming
this podcast is now finished if you'd
like to hear me supplicate for another
few seconds then continue listening to
my 100 not repetitive plead for
donations it's support from the patrons
aka the splendid and munificent and the
sponsors aka those brave enough to
invest in a channel on mathematical
physics consciousness and god teetering
as close as you can to being deepak
chopra without being deepak that allowed
me to do this full time every dollar
helps tremendously thank you
[Music]
you